(music)
I would say the honors co-op program made
it possible for me to have the career
I have now.
Um. I really was an electrical engineer, and that's all I was when I got out of
undergraduate school.
Um. I don't think I would have been able
to succeed in with essentially a
undergraduate school.
Um. I don't think I would have been able
to succeed in what's essentially a
software career,
um, had I not done the honors co-op
program.
This honors co-op program really benefited
me professionally because
I was able to get some exposure to what
the business world is like.
And found out that's something I like to do.
And subsequently,
at least at Xerox, I was able to move away
from an engineering career path, to, um,
moving to the strategic business office.
The honors co-op program had a very deep impact on my professional development, ah,
because it really gave me the skills
that ah I need to do my job today,
which is no longer pure engineering, but a
much broader
sense of whole business management.
I, as a hiring manager, and, ah, am looking for talent, when I see a
Stanford Master's degree
on that resume, first of all, I know what it
means to get one.
And I actually put on my resume not only
that I got my master's degree, but I also
did it during the time when I was working.
(silence)